three days ago my daughter said I think
I'm non-binary because she saw on social
media let's say I bring her to you you
send this to a therapist therapy sees us
a couple of times sends us back to you
in order to see a doctor to be
prescribed hormones
potentially yes
Jesus [__] Christ in the states
oftentimes if anything about gender gets
brought up in a pediatrician's office
they immediately just refer you to the
gender Center so I could be getting an
intake where a kid maybe told their
parent three days ago that they thought
they were non-binary and asking for they
them pronouns and yet they're already
Landing in a specialized Medical Clinic
that does hormones
so there were some intakes where it was
just it made absolutely no sense the
entire concept of kids being allowed to
explore their gender and explore these
Concepts have been almost wiped off the
map
and what would happen let's say I bring
my 12 year old daughter to you three
days ago she said that she's non-binary
she wants their them pronouns what
happens to her from there
so initially I would try to be
encouraging you as a parent to find a
therapist and start working with
therapist for your kid
[Music]
um
but
the minute you're talking to me on the
phone you have already started on a
pathway
because the only therapists that I have
to refer your kid to
our therapists who are going to affirm
their gender identity not question it at
all and potentially as soon as I say
take your kid to that therapist that
therapist might see them for one or two
visits and send them right back to the
center to get started and seen by the
people that prescribe hormones
so three days ago my daughter said I
think I'm non-binary because she saw on
social media let's say I bring her to
you you send us to a therapist therapy
sees us a couple of times sends us back
to you in order to see a doctor to be
prescribed hormones
potentially yes
Jesus [__] Christ sorry for my
language okay yeah so I
uh let's look at this what do we mean by
puberty blockers what do we mean by
these drugs and what are the potential
side effects of these drugs
so the puberty blockers we were using
were mostly their implants that go into
the arm or their injectables that are
used on a monthly or three month basis
um in our Center you had to be at least
in the very initial start of puberty to
get a puberty blocker
um but one of the things we were
starting to see was that some of the
kids put on the puberty blockers mental
health was getting worse once they
started the blocker and that's against
what the narrative tells us the
narrative says these interventions are
supposed to make people better and what
we were seeing was parents calling and
saying my child has had the Blocker in
for a month they're crying every day
they've had the Blocker in for three
months and they're now failing out of
school
um things that were supposed to be
gutter getting better were getting worse
in the center that I worked in
I started there when we were still
supposed to be operating Under The W
path
guidelines standard of care seven which
had some age kind of
ideas for when people were supposed to
start hormones
um wpath 7 was supposed to be 16 and it
said only in rare and you know kind of
urgent cases should you be under the age
of 16. we were pretty much putting
anybody on testosterone at 13 and a half
if that's what they wanted and they got
to us in time and what does that do to
you if you are a young person who's been
given testosterone well it depends
okay and
then put you on a cross-sex hormone we
are potentially
basically
causing you to be infertile for life
and testosterone
um
you know the the effects that kids
reported that they wanted
happen pretty quick so we would
permanently affect your voice and your
voice would be dropped into a male pitch
you would see growth on your clitoris
into what we would refer to as a micro
penis
um we would start seeing atrophy and
your vaginal Canal would start to have
atrophic features
your
all of your body fat would start to move
and shift around you would have facial
hair growth a lot of our patients would
start to start losing the hair on the
top of their head
and then
we would see mood changes we would see
patients who were
again they were supposed to be getting
better their mental health was supposed
to be getting better A lot of times it
was not doing what we thought it was
going to do and if you were on
feminizing hormones you would start
growing breast tissue your fat would
move
um and again if you were put on blockers
first it would render you potentially
infertile for life and now we also know
for
the kids the the boys if we block you
and put you on feminizing hormones we
also are potentially making you have
sexual dysfunction for life
what do you mean by sexual dysfunction
so in the boys
blockers make it so that they never grow
the penis or the testicles
if you never go through
puberty and you never have those
hormones affect that area you are left
with the same kind of penis size that
you would have that kids have when
they're little before they go through
puberty
and then also
we
knew that the feminizing hormones would
make it so you had a lot of erectile
dysfunction the testicles would shrink
and atrophy
and we would be
causing changes to that part of the body
that were irreversible
I hate to State the obvious but those
are some pretty major changes for a
young person to undergo an experience
and the fact that
a young person
could have that start happening to them
after seeing a therapist twice in an
endocrinologist once to me does not
ethically line up
everybody
foreign